Okay, let's work on the solution for our ROB timing quiz this time.
So the question is, when does the add and multiply issue and
when do they commit. For issue, the add will try to issue in the third cycle,
if we have a reservation station available, and we do, because we
are currently using both of the multiply dividers reservation station, but
the add 1 is free. So the add issues in cycle three. And the next instruction,
multiplication, we'll try to issue in cycle 4.
The question is whether we have a free reservation station. Indeed we do,
because we have begun executing the multiplication in cycle 3 here.
That has freed one of the two reservation stations we were holding. So,
pretty much, at cycle 4 both of the multiplied divided reservation stations
are actually available so we can issue in cycle four. So I'll put this here,
so we have 3 and 4. When does this execute? Because, to figure out the commit,
we actually have to figure out also when do they execute and
write the results? The add D uses R7 and R8. Those are not written by any of
the previous instructions so the add can actually begin execution cycle 4.
And because it takes only one cycle it will try to write the result in cycle 5.
Now the multiplication is already writing the result in cycle 5.
But we said that we can't broadcast one add result and
one multiply result in the same cycle. This is a multiply, this is a divide, so
they can actually go in the same cycle, so this will broadcast the result,
also in cycle 5, now let's see what happens with the multiplication here.
It issues in cycle 4, it uses R1 and R2. So it actually
cannot execute until both of those results have been written by instructions,
divide and multiply here. So we have to wait for the later of these two,
which is cycle 6. That's when we dispatch, we can begin execution in cycle 7.
This is a multiplication, these two cycles. So,
in cycles 7 and 8, it is executing in cycle 9, it will write its result.
Now we are ready to figure out the commit. We said that we can commit up to two
instructions per cycle. In cycle 8 we are committing the multiplication here.
The question is can we commit another instruction the same cycle,
because normally we could if the instruction is done? And
indeed it is because this instruction has been ready to commit since cycle 5,
all it was waiting for is for the commit point to reach there.
So in cycle 8 here we will commit it, thus the correct answer for
the commit here is eight. And now finally, we need to figure out,
when does the multiplication commit. Well, it cannot commit in cycle 9,
because it doesn't have a result written yet, then. But it will try to commit in
cycle 10, and by that time, previous instructions have committed,
we have a result. So indeed, it commits in cycle 10. So we can write 10 here.